ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show I am Tim Dylan week 3 of
quarantine I believe right week 3 were
in week 3 of quarantine in the United
States of America
most states now have stay at home orders
non-essential business closed in most of
the country there has never been a time
when every piece of news has been
equally horrifying there's never been a
time when every article every click
everything that you see is as
nightmarish as every other thing that
you see it is a wave it's like if you've
ever been to a beach and you get knocked
down by a wave and you keep trying to
get up and you keep getting knocked down
and then you're just laying there in the
surf that's what this is I mean this is
an amazing period of time I mean and the
media makes it worse I mean it's bad
it's undeniably bad in fact it's so bad
the only joy you have is calling people
and telling them that they don't know
how bad it really is that's the only
bright part of your day is calling
someone in the morning and letting them
know that they don't even know how [ __ ]
they are you get those calls every day
we all compete to deliver the bad news
we're all like Paul Revere except we're
not riding through the night on a horse
we're sitting on our couch watching
Netflix and then every morning we pick
up our phone and call somebody go home
boy you got a C listen this quarantines
not ending there's gonna be chips in our
arm it's you know we're not going back
to work anytime soon kids aren't going
to school in the fall college is getting
pushed back you're never gonna eat out
in a restaurant again
everybody you know is dead you were
dying
you only have one lung working right now
you're looking I feel kind of good shut
up you don't know how [ __ ] you are
that's the only bit of joy we have you
get giddy you get giddy you get giddy
and I like to call people cuz most
people I know now have resigned
themselves to the fate that this is
going to be a long hard slog as Donald
Rumsfeld would say but every now and
then you'll catch somebody with a little
hope with a little hope with a little
like spark of hope and you get excited
because you know you're about to crush
it cuz you know you're about to
extinguish their tiny amount of hope
they go yeah man they go you know
probably start opening up in the summer
and you go oh you ignorant piece of [ __ ]
you know nothing have you not read
anything 30% unemployment massive bank
failures a rise in homelessness the
pandemic will never end they go yeah
yeah I guess what's gonna change between
now and July tell me nothing I got yeah
you hear them sink sink a little bit
lower and then you go all right talk
soon
it's the only choice you have now is
bringing people down and then sometimes
it's fun to lift them up a little
because you got to lift them back up to
crush him again so I call people every
other day and do good good cop bad cop
so yesterday I called everybody told
them quarantine was going to log is to
push in school back in September comedy
clubs will never reopen they all had to
get new jobs and that you know we're
gonna see millions of deaths today I
called him with good news you know I
cherry picked some you know some some
some you know positive news you know
which there's very little off by the way
just surreal and then I lifted them up a
little bit and I like to confuse them
they don't know they don't know where
I'm coming from they don't know where
I'm going with it because sometimes I
like to give because sometimes I'll be
I'll be real down and then up then
they'll be real down but then I want to
go motivational
and I go but but here's what you got to
realize but my motivational is different
than other because this was tuning
errors telling people I was going listen
we're gonna be ok I'll tell you why and
they go why cuz they're in New York I
mean they're shut in New York is America
is Italy right now they're they're
singing in the streets I mean it's wild
you know what I mean and as of New
Yorkers the guys that grew up in New
York it's [ __ ] wild to watch you know
from LA you know um you know not there
I'm not there and you know like my
friend was like she's like everyone
there such annihilate such a narcissist
she's like I'm glad I'm in New York
I'd rather experience this with New
Yorkers and I'm like well good for you
she goes that's where we differ I said
indeed absolutely I'm glad we've
identified that divergence of opinion
but I was saying today I said the
American economy's gonna get back on
track because Americans don't put any
value on human life their own or others
and that is a good thing it is a good
thing that we are a deeply suicidal
country with a death wish it is a good
thing that we arm ourselves to the teeth
and sit in our little survival bunkers
waiting to be allowed out so we can go
walk our fat asses onto a cruise like
nothing ever happened
it's gonna happen again those boats will
be full people are gonna be back in
Applebee's putting quesadillas in their
ass because that's what we're about
they're gonna be back to friendly fire
incidents in their home their
four-year-olds gonna find the gun they
bought for the pandemic and he's gonna
blow their brains out with it don't
worry about it thank God thank God we
have a country of people who truly don't
care what happens next because that's
the only thing that's gonna save us
Europe is [ __ ] they're gonna sit at
home and ponder we're gonna go right the
[ __ ] out as soon as we can get drunk and
crash our cars don't worry tow trucks
will be working you're gonna be working
GEICO's back in business as soon as we
can get back in our cars and
hit someone we're gonna do it as soon as
we are allowed out we're gonna cause
some problem problems we're gonna cause
some bodily harm and that's what we're
about that's the only reason I am
hopeful I don't trust the government I
don't trust the private sector the only
thing we have left is science truly I
mean the only way out of this is a
vaccine or an antiviral drug like maybe
this chloroquine ein helps that they're
that they're giving to people alongside
erythromycin which is the you know the
drug from a z-pack you take for
bronchitis maybe that gets approved as
an official treatment it did in France
maybe that helps
maybe there's another antiviral that is
in the public policy solutions here are
not going to please anybody there are no
good solutions there are waves of this
pandemic there's waves of the virus you
let people back out the numbers will
spike the number spike the hospital
suffer you don't let people back out the
economy crumbles you know it's not
there's no way out as Thomas Sowell said
no solutions only trade-offs here and no
good trade-offs either I mean it's just
you got to decide at one point what is
the more destructive path but you're
worrying you know you know you're
waiting for science you're waiting for a
guy in a lab coat that's a hell of a lot
smarter than me or anyone I know who's
[ __ ] feverishly working on a vaccine
for this because god help you if you
think Donald Trump or Joe Biden is gonna
figure a way to put the world back
together it's not gonna happen in the
short term or the long term your best
hope is science and science takes a
while that's why everybody's freaked the
[ __ ] out the average length of time that
it takes to get a vaccine going is 15 to
18 months that's
not terribly encouraging that's what
most experts are saying and until we get
that most articles that are dribbling at
now are preparing people for a longer
haul than they originally were they're
saying that life is not going to go back
to normal until we have the ability to
prevent people from being hospitalized
so that could be done with a vaccine or
that could be done with an antiviral
that somehow prevents hospitalization so
that it becomes what people said it was
a bad flu for those 20% of people that
would have been the hospitalized it
becomes what it is for those 80% of
people a bad flu and again this is all
as of Friday you know April second third
it's the third
yeah Friday April 3rd April 4th we could
have an entirely new that's what's great
you could wake up on April 4th and they
could go oh ho by the way I remember how
we told everyone to wear masks now
everyone should wear hazmat suits
if you leave your home so please put on
the hazmat suit before you go to the
grocery store and everybody's gonna walk
around looking like astronauts why the
[ __ ] do I have to wear a mask if I'm
alone walking around an area that I'm
too poor to live in which is what I do
every day
I walk around Beverly Hills alone I
don't talk to anyone nobody talks to me
it's LA nobody spoke to each other
pre-pandemic we leave each other alone
why I'm not six feet from anyone why do
I have to wear a mask is the virus just
sitting around in the air stop if it was
truly airborne everyone would have it
stop it I get it if you're gonna go to a
grocery store if you're gonna have an
interaction with somebody but I'm
certainly not wearing a [ __ ] mask to
walk down the street if I'm not near
anybody I understand in New York
everybody's next to you I get it you
know I'm just asking the media to give
us a minute give us a minute
not every story like the medias now like
the stories are like transgender
surgeries are being put off because of
its like okay can you give us a minute
here abortions are not being provided
sigh daddy's sad but can you give us a
minute with it do you have to unearth
every negative thing that's happening
now don't we have enough every human
interest story and I get that these are
stories that need to be told
do we have to tell them all at once do
we have to tell them all at once at
least we waited till the towers fell in
9/11 before we started printing up the
stories of the dead Debra was a mother
of six her lung collapse like oh my god
it's bad I know if the people are still
playing frisbee shoot him if they're not
taking it seriously shoot um I guess I
don't know but to stop writing these
stories you're trying to guilt people to
stay in but they're not gonna do it the
NYPD the LAPD they shoot people for a
lot less than this I'm not saying if
you're jogging or walking but if you're
in a park with a lot of people I don't
know shoot him you don't have to kill
him rubber bullets gasps um tear gas
what are we finding I don't know I mean
you know there's no good options is what
I'm saying here you know I don't want it
to radical government but I'm just
saying if I saw a bunch of [ __ ]
tick-tock kids in LA getting tear gassed
I might smile a little bit
I mean you know what are we waiting for
everybody send me these send me these
conspiracy things about agenda 401 at
the build
18 what it's like guys if they did it if
they release the virus when it's like if
they're willing to do that what I mean
woody or do you even want to know at
that point just buy some heroin and get
ready to meet what's on the other end of
this I mean guys at a certain point well
what is uncovering the truth even
[ __ ] do for you I don't personally
believe they did this cuz I think they
want to they would rather us making
money at our [ __ ] jobs and sitting in
the house while the world economy
collapses but if they did and this is
some way to wipe the slate clean and
they're willing to do this well then
what the f-- I mean at a certain point
you got a [ __ ] roll over I guess I
don't know I mean I don't know what to
tell ya if Bill Gates release this virus
I mean what are you gonna do you know
are you gonna do tweet about it I mean
well you know at that point what did you
have a militia you ready to go well you
got a few guns in the back you shoot at
your tree in Georgia I'm I don't know if
these people really did that then I tend
to believe that was probably some
accident it's probably a Chinese
bioweapon it probably leaked out of that
lab and Wu Han I don't know how it did
maybe they still were selling bats maybe
they're selling animals that they
experimented on that seems the most
probable thing is it weird that it
happened during the Hong Kong protest
yes but I also think that you know
potentially you know China didn't have
any problems shooting tear gas at those
protesters charlie didn't have any issue
doing that so I mean is it is it
impossible to say that they released it
to get rid of it no but I don't know
that they did you know it could have
happened you know and again to trying to
release this to just say [ __ ] it let's
see what happens
who knows I don't know I don't know you
don't know but what so as Raycom said I
was talking to today it's like so what's
the plan go to the beach like what are
we all supposed to do in fact everybody
that we know is that the move even if
we know it's a bioweapon is the move to
just go out and all get sick and that a
lot of people die that doesn't seem
logical well it's the bioweapon from
China so what you still have to protect
yourself your family to a degree you
have to be ethical
you know I've a friend who's gonna fly
to New York to visit his girlfriend I'm
like are you out of your [ __ ] mind
dude what are you doing this is the
stand the Stephen King miniseries on TV
did my father allowed me to watch
because he allowed me to watch most
things in the 90s that was his style of
parenting he said if you want to watch
it you can watch it the movie se7en sure
not a problem whatever you want to watch
you want to watch dead man walking you
want to see a Sean Penn get lethal
injection what are you seven you'll
enjoy this come on it's playing up the
block I don't want to pay for a
babysitter I want to go watch casino you
ever seen someone get buried alive
you're about to handle it handle it like
a man that's a great thing about boomers
who had all had one kid the only kid
houses we would go out with our parents
to dinner with their friends you know
and their friends would talk about
things that were inappropriate for us to
hear but it is what it is if you have
two kids or three kids you get a
babysitter or maybe the older kid will
watch the younger kids in my house it
was like that my sons coming don't
censor yourself my sons coming talk
freely about wanting to kill your wife
talk freely about it my son's there he's
nine he'll think it's hilarious and I
did talk freely about it get hammered in
front of him talk about talk about the
drugs you do he won't mind he'll be
doing him soon he'll be doing him within
two or three years get him ready let him
know let him know you were coked out of
your mind the other night you thought
about pushing your wife out of the attic
window that's something a guy really
said I was sitting there was like 11:00
he goes you know I look at my wife
sometimes I go I want to just push her
out of the attic window he goes who
would know the whole table of guys just
red wine laughing it's great
we're great memories III I appreciate
the way I grew up that was a great style
of parenting it's getting real now on
Long Island for even for people that
didn't really grasp because in the
beginning the outlook on this on Long
Island was we you shut the [ __ ] up
that's how it was handled shut up people
have to sit down with the parents ago
you can't golf
you can't go golfing you can't go you
can't have you know you can't go to
Maria's baby shower you can't and you
did have to explain it and they go so
what nobody's sick you know and now it's
those see those those statuses they're
getting they get those people are going
quiet now they're going come of them are
dead but they're going they're getting a
little quiet like to eat just a flu
status that's where I never make these
stupid predict like I never go out there
and I don't take these hard stances you
know when I don't know something because
I've learned that you could only have to
walk it back so if I'd come out and was
like you took the flu it's all fake of
[ __ ] duh I mean we drove by
cedars-sinai one night there weren't a
lot of people there it would have been
easy for me to come on and be like John
or we [ __ ] drove by Cedars there was
no one there they stings fake um
and then now I would have to be looking
at numbers and you know got to walk it
back so you know people are gonna get
real quiet you know they're getting a
little quiet because in the beginning it
was this was you remember that this was
a liberal this was liberal hysteria to
to wreck the economy so Trump would
would get voted out of office this was
the this is what I heard from my people
on Long Island and this was hysteria
somebody I knew wrote their closing the
country down because if sniffles and
Long Island loves World War two memes
they'll be like just the greatest
generation and then and then they'll
show like somebody blowing your nose but
exist generation closed the country down
for it sniffles and the funny thing
about that is the people that share
those memes were never
in the military they never served in the
military came and they loved World War
two although they probably did nothing
for their grandparents that served in
World War two other than rob them the
only thing they did for the greatest
generation was take money off their
mantle okay so but they loved those
World War two memes that are like this
Joe we're [ __ ] now goddamn [ __ ]
this flu sniffles there's still a net no
there's still people doing that by the
way there's still people that are going
you know there's still people with it
the mortality rate and the death toll
and that's all gonna stop it's common
and most people there will be some
people that don't care there will be
people on ventilators right before they
go out you know you know before they're
in a coma there'll be people going so
what this is not I mean it's just trump
2020 will be the last thing certain
people say on long island
Trog that'll be it because you cuz
they'd rather just you know drowned in
their own lungs then unravel their
worldview you know I mean listen man god
bless him let him know that's what it is
if you have a significant other right
now you might be having more sex than
usual you might not be it really depends
I don't know I think I know a lot of
people that are growing to hate each
other more and more every day and what a
blessing that is but it is a good time
to remind you that the Tim Dylan show is
sponsored by manscaped and the engineers
at man skates have spent the last 18
months crafting the perfect vaccine
kidding fall hair trimmer the perfect
ball hair trimmer okay and they've just
released a new and improved ventilator
kidding lawnmower 3.0 smooth out your
scrotum with a new ceramic blade and
manscaped advanced skin safe technology
there's a lot of fancy copywriting that
means it won't Nick or snag your knot
sack the lawnmower 3.0 has a lot of
upgraded features it's the best
tracer system you've ever owned listen I
have one of these I use it a lot of
people I know Ben uses head it's just a
good product you need to manscape you
need to shave your dick if you enjoy our
show it's a great way to support this
show you need these things you could
probably even have it if you're a woman
and you have a penis that was created by
a large vagina in in a transgender
surgery or if you just got a crazy Bush
who cares get 20% off and free shipping
when you use the code team at manscaped
com
that's manscaped calm and use the promo
code Tim for 20% off your first order
that's a lot of [ __ ] money okay you
need a well shave and dick right now
it's important it makes it look a lot
bigger and it'll please your partner or
yourself maybe you're just whacking it
that's okay too you want a jerk a penis
that is well shaven and you feel good
treat yourself well my friend's mother
was a prostitute and she said to me and
my friend once she was a great woman she
sold us drugs and we were in her kitchen
and we were maybe 13 and she said you
know what boys she says don't get any
girls pregnant and if people say how
come you haven't had any accidents you
say cuz I [ __ ] myself I treat myself
good I treat myself real good you could
smell the Southern Comfort on a brush
because I treat myself real good so do
that treat yourself well 20 percent offs
a lot of money
manscaped calm na ma n SCA PE D calm
manscaped calm they've really juiced
this baby up with 7,000 rpm motor with
quiet stroke technology the battery that
lasts up to 90 minutes so you could
shave your dick for an hour and a half
because you do it during the zoom
meeting if you have a zoom meeting for
work to shave your dick for an hour and
a half while you listen to Karen by the
way how is anyone like I haven't had an
office job in years how is anyone even
being productive on these zoom meetings
how is anyone not going we're all gonna
die how in God's name is that not
happening like they're having these zoom
meetings for work and you're all
supposed to act like everything's normal
I mean what's that about you're going
over marketing numbers on a zoom meeting
right now and you're sitting there in
your underwear and you gotta like like
aren't Pete like you're not gonna [ __ ]
you're not gonna just be like hey I'm
gonna go through this report in the
minute but guys what do you think this
is you know you think we make it out you
think you think there's a society on the
other end of this I don't know how to
farm I mean [ __ ] man my wife calls the
other day I thought about not letting
her in my house I love her but I you
know I got to think about myself I'm in
survival mode man I don't know how I'm
gonna provide for my kids
[ __ ] all right well anyway the new
product guidelines that I received seem
to be pretty positive the client enjoys
the package it you know I mean how do
you just it's like doom every day and
then you just got to get on a zoom
meeting and pretend that everything's
okay and you're just sitting there you
just came all over yourself you just
masturbated for 30 minutes and I mean
you really got into it and now it's a
zoom meeting and you gotta sit there
covered in [ __ ] and like look at everyone
that you used to work with and they're
all covered in their own come I mean
manscaped calm twenty percent off free
shipping it's all good goodbye that's a
lot of what I find amazing about this
time it's this new technology you know
it's not new but everybody's using it
now this like zoom or you don't have to
go into your office and you just sit
around in your own filth and then you
know try to be professional you know and
there's people doing zoom comedy shows
because they're insane but
everyone doing that um you're probably
gonna have to get a day job soon and I
don't want to be the bearer of bad news
um but people that have relied on
stand-up comedy as their only source of
income potentially I'm not saying
definitively and nobody I take no joy in
this I think a lot of them may not be
prepared for what's coming and I don't
know if what's coming is going to be an
environment conducive to earning a
living at stand-up it might be I hope it
is but all signs on all systems are
flashing red so I know you think that in
two months you're gonna be back up in
Adam and that's why you're keeping sharp
on the zoom comedy show but I think it's
time to get call mom and dad and
apologize
stop ridiculing your religious family
and start learning hymns you're going
home you're gonna start singing in the
pews my our God is an awesome God that's
right you're gonna marry your high
school sweetheart and dedicate your life
to the Lord you're going home to that
small town you're going to Community
College you're gonna be a waitress at a
local diner and you're gonna get [ __ ]
good by the town bad boy and it's
leather jacket it's pleather probably
but whatever he's gonna [ __ ] you good
and you're gonna remember what old
small-town [ __ ] tastes like and he ain't
smart and he hasn't read Marx's capital
no he's gonna [ __ ] you good in the
basement of his house that's owned by
his alcoholic mother who's very happy to
see you because she thinks you're gonna
save her son's life hello you were
living in New York
oh it's glad to see you're hanging out
with cliff cliff could use a girl like
you he's had a rough couple of years but
he's a good boy mama loves cliff and
you're gonna go and you're gonna suck
his balls and you're gonna lick his
taint and you're not gonna eat his ass
but you should because you're not
going anywhere settle in start becoming
friends with your high school the girl
who used to torment you who was a
cheerleader now she's a fat mother of
three and now you see her as a person
and you don't mind how much he tortured
you you don't mind that because you see
how much she's suffering now and there's
some shouting Freud in it for you and
you two become friends and when Deniz
opens back up you sit there and you'll
wedge yourself in a booth and yet you
scrape the bottom of a bowl of queso and
you eat pancakes and fried shrimp and
food that doesn't even go together cuz
you're back home for good and you've
dedicated your life to Christ now and
you're going to Community College and
you're working as a receptionist at a
construction company that's failing and
your boss and you do coke together and
he hasn't tried to [ __ ] you
but you've already resigned yourself to
the fact that if he tries you're gonna
ride him good cuz you don't have [ __ ]
left it's all over for you six months
ago you were prancing around Brooklyn
telling everybody you were non-binary
and you hated your parents now you're
back home [ __ ] men and praying to
Jesus you're back home eating big fluffy
omelette stuffed with cheddar cheese and
grits no more tuna tartare no more vegan
[ __ ] soup it's all over it all ended
quickly but you realizing that that this
life is actually more real than anything
you experienced in New York or San
Francisco or Chicago this life was the
life you were always meant to live and
you go into that local bar and they know
who you are they say hey baby how are
you and you go to the bartender Erica
cuz she's a friend of yours
and she's got a few bumps of coke for
you and you take a few shots and you
feel like a winner you sit on that
barstool and you light a cigarette and
you feel like a winner for an hour and
then you walk
back out into the cold night terrors
because you have no more money and no
more blow and you go home and you're
toss and turn in your bed as you sweat
and you come down from the devil's
powder and you think about cliff the
town dirtbag who puts his cocking yeah
you think about your fat arch nemesis is
now your only friend you think about
your [ __ ] construction job and you
thought to yourself if you had any sense
you'd get back in your car and drive it
right into the ocean but Denny's ain't
bad those pancakes are fluffy and
they'll be hot tomorrow morning when you
slide them down your throat when you
slide them down your Pig or throat
because you're going home and that's my
message to the people out there that are
confused about what the next steps of
your life are many of you don't know but
that that's what it is
that's where it is okay you're not going
to be they just rescheduled it just for
Laughs comedy festival for October
probably won't happen
these September October it's not
happening folks and if it does happen if
somehow they're pandemic recedes and and
it does happen just just so I don't want
to be wrong I'll go up there as a
suicide bomber and blow it up so if I'm
wrong and jfl happens I will wait to the
new face to showcase and I will walk
onstage and pull the pin and blow it up
and right before I do I'll look at you
right in your face and said told you so
you were going home one way or the other
you're going home you're either going to
Syracuse you're going to see Jesus
because I'm not gonna be wrong it's what
it is Benjamin you notice what it is I
only speak the truth here I'm not here
to I'm not here to pad you I'm not
wearing a mask at Beverly Hills I have a
beautiful face I've her European facial
structure I'm showing it off
it's the only part of my body that
hasn't gone to total [ __ ] I'm not
putting the mask over it she didn't call
the cops and drag me in it's not
happening this pig wasn't wearing a mask
no I was not sure so I live in the
United States of America which is still
a free country although we can't work
fraternize leave our homes walk down the
street but you cannot compel me to wear
a mask what I am NOT near anybody then
let's do the totals it's time to do the
totals we do the totals we try to do the
totals coronavirus case is 1 million
99006 22 deaths 59,000 193 recovered 228
938 don't know what that means don't
know what they mean by recovered I guess
they mean had it and then got better USA
we've got two hundred and seventy seven
thousand cases four hundred and
seventy-five 277 475 okay deaths we have
74 hundred and two so that's where we're
at let's look at the country map again
this is gonna sadly really take a toll
on the third world and I think people in
rural America are not prepared for the
toll it's gonna take on rural America
because even though they're more spread
out they don't live on top of each other
in certain cases they do but I those
hospitals do not have the money or the
resources to accommodate any type of
outbreak so that's gonna be a real issue
but thank God we have Jared Kushner
handling everything because of his
extensive experience in evicting people
he's now going to evict them from life
he's now gonna show people how to evict
them from the planet you know public
health advocate Jared Kushner I feel
good by the way even the die-hard Trump
fans don't love globalist Jared or
Ivanka or the fact that he gave us a fan
jobs even if you're a bad a night
isolationist paleo con you cannot like
[ __ ] the cone in there from Goldman
Sachs and you can't like [ __ ] I tend
to think if you vote for Trump again I
mean you know you know we just get what
we deserve if Trump wins again it's like
listen it is what it is
I don't I will just laugh as I've done
for the last because I'm not gonna Drive
myself crazy but if I mean Biden sucks
he's a bad candidate I get it but if you
think that Donald Trump is handling this
the right way or you think that his
demeanor and tone is appropriate as
nurses and doctors are dropping dead if
you think it's appropriate for the guy
to go out and brag about the ratings of
his press conferences then I don't know
that you I don't know that that you can
be right I didn't fall for Trump but I
didn't fall for Obama I didn't fall for
any of them
I didn't fall for any [ __ ] person who
told me they gave a [ __ ] about me and if
you're a child and you did well I feel
bad for you I feel bad for you if you're
a [ __ ] child and you fell for that
that somebody cared about you and and
just coincidentally that also concei
coincided with them getting the most
powerful position on earth I think it's
time to give somebody else a shot I
would give Bernie Sanders a shot
national healthcare seems like a real
good idea in a world with a pandemic
we've got a pandemic it seems like we're
look yes I know the government is
inefficient I get that I understand that
I don't think that systems gonna be
perfect but our system when you get a
$30,000 bill for the ventilator that
dead Buffalo Wild Wings built for you to
use that's not a good system either so
let's all [ __ ] start to understand
that like we're gonna need to move in a
direction of smart collectivism not in
the sense that you know it's not looks
like we don't want a Maoist country and
the idiots that back Bernie that are
always you know [ __ ] talking landlords
or whatever and like you know you
I do have a funny video coming out this
week about landlords but the people that
think we're never gonna be a Marxist
[ __ ] if she's never gonna happen cut
that [ __ ] out
but the one [ __ ] I mean man I
completely understand the idea that it
is almost suicidal in a country that
that is susceptible to these types of
pandemics to have hundreds you know have
a hundred million people 50 million
people and more than that now because
you're all getting laid off without any
type of coverage that aren't gonna go to
the doctor that will never know if
they're sick that will be going out and
spreading this disease that are not
gonna isolate they're not gonna know if
they have it because they don't want to
get a bill like don't you realize stop
with the isms capitalism socialism it's
you somebody it went on the classroom
okay this to reality keep talking about
capitalism you didn't get it back to the
head you're gonna get a knife to the
throat pretty soon because people gonna
go I want your money and rich people
used to understand [ __ ] like that they
used to understand the like well we
can't be too we can't be put you know we
can't just [ __ ] dangle it in their
faces all the time we gotta have some
type of functional society and if you
think of functional society if somebody
was laid off from their job who goes to
a hospital who ends up on a [ __ ] vent
is gonna get in three months to $30,000
bill from that hospital with no [ __ ]
job and a 1200 dollar payout from the
government if you think that's a good
[ __ ] system I hope you can fight and
I hope you got a lot of weapons and I
know a lot of you fat pigs that listen
to the show think you can't fight and
you think you do have a lot of weapons
but you're gonna be too drunk to find
them when the time comes let's be honest
okay I mean this is the reality in the
situation all these tough guys you know
all the tough guys are Facebook live
with their mom everybody loved these
like these guys just like
libertarian-leaning like guys that are
like oh I value my freedom well you have
the freedom to leave your mother's house
how about the freedom to [ __ ] get out
of your parents house stop telling and
have a little human compassion for a
while I'm sorry that whatever happened
you that you don't care about any other
human being that [ __ ] exists except
yourself I'm sorry that you can't care
about another [ __ ] human being okay I
ran my favourite country fifty three
thousand deaths very sad many people
know that I'm friends with a lot of the
mullahs in Iran that's why I started
comedy no I'm kidding
but a lot of people know my cat and I
don't really own I mean he doesn't live
with me but my cat Oscar lived in Iran
for a few years and was wasn't mullah
was one of the Iranian mullahs he was a
cleric Oscar was a he was he was a
radical Muslim cleric Oscar has been in
many extremist groups he's been an anti
feh he's been in proud boys he's been in
neo-nazis he's been in not all of them I
mean he's been in you know Golden Dawn I
mean he's been in you know radical
communist he was an eco-terrorist for a
while he doesn't really care he just
wants it to burn down
he doesn't care where it comes from but
it's gonna be tough but it's a little
enraging and I'm the furthest thing like
I you know I all these articles that are
coming out that are like this crisis is
a gendered crisis many of the health
care workers through women's to gender
I'm like dude that's not the move and
the move isn't on the right cuz you know
these guys are gonna start putting out
articles with like rich people in masks
and they're gonna go the viruses has
made us all one it showed us we're all
vulnerable its flattened us we're all
the same we bleed too and it's just
gonna be pictures of you know and it's
like now we're not all the same you're
quarantine in a mansion you have the
money to pay for medical care there are
people right now that are [ __ ]
worrying this through no fault of their
own they're worrying about getting
thrown out on the street and then if I
say something about that people like
you're a [ __ ] we want liberal and
Hollywood Hollywood doesn't exist
anymore dummy it shut down it shut down
and there's nothing liberal about not
wanting people to be [ __ ] on the
street do you want to walk through a
gang of violent hungry people every day
is that a good functional society even
if you don't care about people and you
only care about yourself don't you think
it's
interest to not have a third of the
country on the street begging for food
how high do you think these gates are
none of these I know where all these
rich communities are in LA you could
climb that fence you could climb the
fins of the most elite communities in
this country you could climb a [ __ ]
fence you're right in there you're right
in there I mean there's probably ones I
don't know about and they'll they're
bigger than trust me they'll start
building them they're gonna start
building ones who are a little tougher
to get into and they have their own
water you know Montana they have
properties with their own water aquifers
and [ __ ] like that but I take heat from
people sometimes four people are like
you know and I as soon as this crisis
end I will go back to being against
health care workers I'm against them
I've always been against nurses I've
always been against nurses and I've
never liked doctors and it's very hard
for me now to have to like them but I do
and I get them lunch when I can cuz it's
a good thing to [ __ ] do because
that's all we can do we can do nothing
else but I can I can order delivery that
is one of my skills I can or I could
call an Italian restaurant in Jersey and
have them drop off food at a hospital
and you can [ __ ] - okay so while
you're waiting for the storm while
you're waiting for a 500,000 rich
pedophiles to be picked up by the
military during the period of the
internet being taken down while you're
waiting for that if you have a little
money go order some penne alla vodka for
the local nurses that are gonna drain
your lungs of fluid if they have to okay
because queuing on whoever that is is
probably not gonna be able to end to
hook you up to ventilator and and I've
said I will apologize if queueing on is
correct nothing would make me happier
than seeing rich pedophiles arrested
especially some of them that the people
that you guys say are pedophiles if they
all ended up being pedophiles and get
arrested I would laugh my ass off and I
would be like hey I'd wear a qyn on
shirt I'd be like this is it now you
guys were right hey I was wrong I would
tell everyone that's all we would say
for the rest of our lives by the way if
humans right all any of us would say for
the rest of our lives is you kidding I
couldn't believe it I thought they were
[ __ ] and and it turned out they're
[ __ ] Tom Hanks [ __ ] guy I had no
idea
and so they shut the internet down and
they brought over these hospital ships
to New York and we thought they were
gonna be dead too you know to help
people that were affected by his
pandemic but they were like filled with
[ __ ] Hollywood celebrities that were
arrested I mean wow my favorite thing in
the tweet is that they say during the
three days they're the the the TV's
gonna come on and they're gonna explain
to everyone that the world is run by a
satanic pedophile cult that's my
favorite thing only because I want to
know how they're gonna get into it like
what newscaster do they choose to break
that news to the public what newscaster
do they choose to be like to be like
hello everyone welcome to the program
today as you can imagine we have some
special breaking news you may have
noticed that the Internet has been shut
down and you can't use the phone except
to call 911 asking yourself why is it
some type of outage correct it's
actually a forced outage because well
let's all just rip the band-aid off the
world is run by a satanic pedophile call
Tom Hanks is in it and we had to fake a
pandemic to arrest Tom Hanks now I know
some of you might have questions some of
you might have a few and this is not to
say that there aren't pedophiles or that
they're not very powerful but that some
of them art satanic I don't really care
about the religion of the pedophiles by
the way these people seem to leave that
Catholic pedophile why I don't
understand what about a Methodist
pedophile are they not a problem but I
understand that I've done I've done
interviews on my show with the foremost
experts in this with none of them
believe in this theory Nick Bryant who
wrote the Franklin scandal
believe that Donald Trump is freeing to
none of them believe this and these are
the guys that wrote the books on the
[ __ ] things that you people have
understand but if I'm telling you right
now if it happens if it comes to
fruition and I again I'm still in the
camp that would would rate that unlikely
but if it comes to fruition
I will apologize and I will just say hey
hey I was er off there but if it doesn't
now I challenge you if it doesn't happen
can we let it go now not not stop trying
to protect kids not trying to not stop
trying to [ __ ] bring people to
justice but can we stop believing that
this [ __ ] thing you think is gonna
happen it's gonna happen can you grow up
can you [ __ ] grow up if it doesn't
happen if there's no internet outage and
they don't and I love that you dummies
are like there's 500,000 sealed
indictments like they're gonna need
indictments if it's really that bad and
they're getting they're taking a satanic
pedophile cult that controls the world
too taking them into custody they're
gonna read them their rights they're
gonna do indictments they're gonna go by
the book they're gonna make it by the
book if they're all living on
adrenochrome and murdering kids are
gonna be like oh we don't treat
terrorists like we're gonna treat them
we're gonna treat them better than we
treat terrorists like we're gonna we're
gonna we're gonna read them their rights
we throw Arab guys in Guantanamo Bay
who've done nothing but we're gonna read
Tom Hanks his rights we could hand him a
suit make sure he's indicted properly
and brought through the system if he's
been living off the adrenochrome
harvested from scared children and
sacrifices you really think we need
indictments at that point guys guys this
is what happens when you take a few
nuggets of something that's undeniably
true that the world is run by sick
freaks the world is run by some very
sick people not all of them but a lot of
them they're into heinous [ __ ] some of
it includes the abuse of children and
the murder of children a hundred percent
but if you think that all the justice is
being
delivered uh tomorrow for that I think
you're wrong and I'm a conspiracy guy
like I'm a guy that is very receptive to
a lot of these ideas and thinks here's
what you do if how about this what about
this storm give everyone that's not a
pedophile
a Ridge wallet there's a lifetime
warranty if you love it in free returns
if you don't Ridge wallet is a small
sleek metallic front-facing wallet it
fits a few credit debit cards maybe a
crisp hundred-dollar bill
so you could take it out and roll and do
some cocaine with somebody who's of age
whatever Ridge forces you to streamline
everything in your pocket one of the
saddest memories of my father is when
he'd take out this big leather wallet of
business cards the people that wouldn't
do business with him you'd have wads of
cash falling out it was just a Boomer
wallet look like an old baseball glove
not the ridge wallet it's sleek it's
sexy and fun and and and it's it's pet
you can spray it you can Lysol it
especially now in a pandemic you can
clean that Ridge quick rub some hand
sanitizer on your hand and rub it on the
ridge it's easy to Lysol easy to wipe
down with a lifestyle wipe it's very
important it is actually one of the most
hygienic wallets wallets you can have
which is important now it is important
to have a hygienic wallet it's important
to not carry a lot of [ __ ] the more [ __ ]
you carry the more surfaces for the
virus to live on the less surfaces to
the virus to live on you're doing good
you're doing good because we want to
respect what's happening I want to do
the right thing we don't want to lose
our minds here the only thing we have
left is our minds think about that the
only thing you have left right now is
your mind your job is kind of gone you
can't go anywhere
they've taken most of your friends
they've taken it all from you and it's
because of
germs but all you've got left right now
is your mind your mental dexterity your
ability to reason if you lose that you
lose everything
so get 10% off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to Ridge
comm slash Tim T I am that's Ridge
dot-com slash Tim T I am and use the
code T I am link in description get a
high genic sleek wallet super important
go to Drudge there's a few funny
articles Henry Kissinger writes in
article pandemic alters world order
which is you know just one of the
peanuts like we need you know we need
and you know there's an argument for
this I mean Kissinger of course is a war
criminal said she said you know he's you
know grandpa genocide but he's like we
need more global cooperation to defeat
these types of pandemics you know
potentially potentially I also think it
was probably not a good idea to have
everything built in other countries
because corporations didn't want to pay
their workers so now you know look at
the percentage of medicine it's made in
China this is jarring this is the amount
this is a percentage of pharmaceuticals
that are made in [ __ ] China okay
[Music]
American pharmaceuticals made in China
go to which medicines are made in China
I'm telling you go to go down here's
what's made in China okay
drugs for blood pressure medicine
Alzheimer's Parkinson's epilepsy
depression so much [ __ ] dude ibuprofen
go to ibuprofen how much of that they
make in China dude so much of the
over-the-counter medications and even
serious medications that people need are
made in China this is the problem when
you outsource everything if you have a
war if there's the supply chain
breakdown you cannot get the types of
medications that you need last month the
US China economic and security review
Commission held a hearing on the United
States growing reliance on China's
pharmaceutical products ninety seven
percent of all antibiotics in the US
came from China
ninety
7% of all antibiotics come from China
centralization of the global supply
chain of medicines in a single country
makes it vulnerable to interruption
whether by mistake or design if we're
dependent on China for thousands of
ingredients and raw materials to make
our medicine
China could use this dependence as a
weapon against us at any time so even if
you don't care about workers you don't
care about wages you certainly care
about your kids getting medication you
certainly care about at ninety seven
percent of all antibiotics and there's
other stuff too so I mean this is part
of the reason that I think that it's
kind of a fantasy to suggest I do think
you need globe the global cooperation to
defeat pandemics and and threats of that
nature but I think it's this you know
globalization which is truly just this
financial system that has you know
primarily benefited wealthy people or
benefited people in certain industries
and has decimated large swathes of the
country and a lot of workers that system
is the system that allows a lot of
essential products to be made in labor
markets where the labor costs of
producing those products is the lowest
and that becomes a problem it becomes a
big problem when you can't get those
[ __ ] products so you know Henry
Kissinger goes out there with a not bad
and he's like well we need you know we
don't want to put up more walls and we
don't want to you know but it's like hey
buddy so here here uh you know so we go
down here to my favorite paragraph go
down a little bit he goes leaders are
dealing with this crisis on a largely
national basis but the virus society
dissolving effects do not recognize
borders while the assault on human
health will hopefully be temporary the
political and economic upheaval it has
unleashed could last for generations
no country not even the US can in a
purely national effort overcome the
virus addressing the necessities of the
movement must ultimately be coupled with
agloe
collaborative vision and program true
but some of the economic upheaval are
gonna be people going we're living in a
[ __ ] system that doesn't work Henry
we're living in a system that's not
[ __ ] working for anybody some of the
economic upheavals gonna be people kind
of wake in the [ __ ] up
and he's like we need a global
collaborative vision and program how
much do you want it bad that global
collaborative vision doesn't include
anybody that makes under you know ten
million dollars a year how many people
are gonna be collaborating that aren't
millionaires not not many I understand
that you don't want to be an
isolationist country the Fox News people
that just keep yelling China over and
over again you know Trump is so good he
knew he knew cuz what the left should
have done is when he said it's the
Chinese virus the left could have said
hey man we don't care what you call it
we should have had tests why didn't we
have tests that's the you know that's
and that stops his that doesn't give him
but the left has to write all these
iPads about like stop calling it the
title off and then so trumping out there
they're in a tit-for-tat about what you
call the foe who cares why didn't we
have tests why are you bragging about
the ratings on a press calm but you know
everybody just Falls for it man and if
you're old enough and you're smart
enough you you simply realize that these
political solutions are not gonna work
and you just hope to God for science you
pray that somebody smarter than anybody
that we know is gonna figure a way out
of this because the people that did that
we that are tasked right now with
solving this problem they don't have a
clue I mean Jared Kushner he doesn't
have a clue I mean good luck but keep
doing what you do and keep keep getting
through it keep calling people every day
with bad news it makes you feel a little
better keep calling them wake them up
with it oh sorry did I wake you
you got to hear what I read gotta hear
what I read there's a study coming out
of China right now
that says rats to get coronavirus grow
to six feet long they're eating dogs
they'll be here soon anyway have a good
day how you holding up
everybody's calling you now they're
saying that how you holding up how are
you holding up as soon as they say that
ask for money oh good can I get it can I
get a towel can I get a grand I'm doing
good I love a thousand dollars I love a
thousand cash please I want to buy some
masks you know but I mean you know we
had a lot of fun on the patreon not to
plug the patreon but the Patriot APUs
ODEs are really funny really good you
know I mean we do try to put work into
them we don't ask you to pay for it
something that sucks we do try to put
work but we try to do with the Patriot
Pasillas their audio only but we drive
around trying to drive around and it's
funny and I have a different a little
bit of a different vibe but I'm driving
I feel free I used to love to drive I
used to love to blow a few lines of
cocaine on my nose and drive my dad's
Mississippi she gallant until I smashed
it into that front into the car with
some some grandmother but she lived she
lived enough so grandmother with the
kids
I got her head on I made a left turn
from the right lane and ruined her day
smacked my Secretary's head on - she
lived she's a big woman but I used to
love to drive the freedom the freedom of
driving with nowhere to go just driving
through the wasteland of the culture
just driving through the pandemic seeing
the boarded up storefronts seeing the
people looking at you from their houses
wondering if you've come to take what
they have and make it yours
looking at the suspicious people and the
scared children and the pets that don't
quite understand what's going on
looking at the shuttered bars and
performance spaces seeing the Comedy
Store with these very [ __ ] spooky
sign that doesn't have any names on the
marquee it just says stay healthy
something you'd find in an apocalyptic
film in a
dirted town when you were trying to
figure out what the hell happened we're
living in a movie folks we're living in
a movie and you're in the movie you're
in the movie I don't know for how long I
don't know how long I'll be in the movie
that's the fun about the movie we don't
know when and if this ends we're all
filled with uncertainty and we're
concocting stories and ideas in our head
to try to make it okay we have to we're
pattern-seeking creatures we want
justice enter the queue and on people we
want explanations for why this is
happening we haven't fully truly given
ourselves to the randomness and cruelty
of whatever this existence is maybe it
is a simulation maybe it's not maybe
we're just fungus on a rock and not
nothing means anything and we're just
here and and you know the few moments
you get listening to my show or you know
having kids or whatever makes you happy
you know those few moments make it all
worthwhile because that's truly what it
is you got to resign yourself to that
now you have to prepare yourself to die
folks I mean that's really what it is
you have to prepare yourself for the end
because nobody is guaranteed tomorrow
okay and you got to think about how you
want to live the rest of your days you
have to prepare now prepare for the end
and the way that you're gonna prepare
for the end is move back in with your
religious parents and start [ __ ]
cliff the town bad boy become friends
with your arch nemesis from high school
she's a fat [ __ ] and she's got stretch
marks on her neck and you become friends
with her and you eat at Denny's with her
late at night and you start smoking
cigarettes and doing coke and you hang
out in a local bar with a fat bartender
named Erica and you let your boss at the
construction company pump you and cheat
on his wife as he shoves his half-hard
penis into your vagina and you don't
even wash it anymore because what does
it matter it all becomes one smell your
vag and the dirty Denny's floor it all
becomes one smell and it's not a bad
smell and it's not a good smell it just
smells warm and rotten but when you
smell it you realize what that smell is
it's home it's home and we're all going
home one way or another
see you next week
[Music]